It doesn't make any sense
but she's gonna make sense.
Okay.
Take a look.
For the the last year and a half,
I've been on a quest to trade a single bobby pin
up until I get to a house.
After 28 trades, and all the ups and downs.
I finally did it.
Okay, we're walking up to it.
This feels so surreal.
(audience cheering)
She got a house?
Wow.
So here to tell this how this insane true story happened
is Demi Skipper.
Demi, hi.
(audience cheering)
Hi guys.
Wow.
Take me back to May, 2020.
Where did this idea and bobby pin come from?
Yes. So May of 2020,
I think like a lot of us, I was sitting in quarantine,
watching too much TV and came upon a Ted talk
about a guy that had done this 20 years ago.
And I looked, and he was the only person.
So I knew I had to be the second one to do it.
So I grabbed a bobby pin and then started trading.
What?
What's the step...
What are the steps?
(Drew blabbering)
You start with a bobby pin and a dream for a house.
What do you even do with step one?
So there's the bobby pin.
Then what?
Yes, so great question.
So I looked honestly around my own house and said
"What do I have a lot of?"
I found a pack of bobby pins.
I have them sitting all around my house.
So I took one of those bobby pins
and made my first trade with Abby,
who was someone I did not know,
just random stranger online,
but now we still keep in touch.
So Abby wasn't like, "Why are you trying to hawk
a bobby pin that I could find
in the bottom of my dirty purse?
She instead said like, "I'm intrigued",
and traded a pair of earrings?
Is this correct?
So I knew that she was part of my posse when she said,
"You know what?"
"I will trade you a pair of earrings
I got for my birthday but you have to invite me
to the house at the end."
And I was like, "This girl gets me."
She knows me...
Like this is my person.
So you were transparent
about the building blocks of the mission?
Yes.
What an intelligent approach to share the story.
'Cause I so believe in a collective experience
and I do believe we wanna lift each other up.
And you are living proof that that is the case.
Yeah, totally.
Yes.
(audience applauding)
I'm curious though.
It took you a year and a half,
like what did you end up trading for the house?
Great question.
So there are 28 trades total.
So I did not just go from a bobby pin
and then got a house and it was over.
There were many ups and downs.
My final trade was a $40,000 food truck trailer.
So it had solar panels, a battery.
So everything you needed
to start your own food truck company essentially.
And someone traded me that for the house.
Is it true that there was a tractor also at one point?
Oh yes, there were three tractors involved,
which I drove myself.
I've never driven a tractor,
but that tractor was part of the trades.
It then traded for a Chipotle Celebrity card,
which is unlimited Chipotle for a year.
Didn't know what that was.
Now you're talking.
Yeah.
So somebody traded me for a lifetime supply of burritos,
and then she traded for that off-the-grid trailer
that I just told you about.
And then that went to the house.
And just outta curiosity,
where did you park the trailer in the meantime?
Oh, let me tell you.
I live in San Francisco.
I don't have a car of my own.
This was a journey in and of itself-
Oh my God.
San Francisco's the hardest city to park in.
With a a tractor.
Oh, three of them too.
No not one, three.
Oh my...
It's just me walking down the street with three tractors.
So, I found a very gracious friend who had a large garage.
Okay, so I have three rapid fire questions.
Okay.
Are you full of memories now from this journey?
Yes. I mean honestly, I thought that I would trade
a bobby pin for a house and I knew I would get there
even if it took five years.
But you meet so many people along the way.
You end up learning so much about yourself.
It became so much more than just, "Is it possible?"
It became like the people and the memories
of the last two years.
Would you, #2, recommend for someone else
to travel this intricate journey that you've taken?
Absolutely.
I think other people should try it.
I will tell them they will get a hundred no's
on every trade until they get their one yes.
So it's not easy, but they can do it.
And #3, how is your new house?
Oh, it is lovely.
I'm so impressed by you.
(audience applauding)
I am so honored that you would share this story with us
because it really is one to wrap your head and heart around.
I can't thank you enough.
Demi Skipper!
(audience applauding)
Well done, Demi.
Thank you for having me.
Who tool her life and changed it.
And you can too.
Thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)